Schon seit Generationen sammelt vorwiegend Buben vor grossen Fussballturnieren Panini-Bildli. Seit sechs Jahren gibt es zu diesen Klassikern auch eine Alternative, das Schutti-Heftli.
Fussball wird eigentlich heute immer fast nur mit Geld verdienen und Geld machen, gleichgesetzt dabei ist es so viel mehr und wir wollen ja ein kleines Zeichen setzen, dass es auch um Leidenschaft geht bei Fussball.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch, heute in einer internationalen Ausgabe. Mein Name ist Max Sackop-Ost, ich bin der Genetzer bei Twitter und freue mich sehr, dass ihr alle zuhört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn wir haben ein ganz, ganz feines Thema heute. Vielleicht habt ihr es im Vorspann schon erahnen können, vielleicht etwas überraschend, der Schweizer-Dütsche-Einschlag in diesem Intro. Wir reden heute über das Schutti-Heftli. Was genau das sein soll? Das werde ich euch jetzt dann gleich erklären, zusammen mit meinen Gästen, die heute mal die Ehre haben, sich selbst vorzustellen. Und beginnen darf gerne der Silvan Glanzmann. Silvan, was müssen wir über dich wissen? Hallo und willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Ja, hallo, freut mich sehr, dass ich hier sein darf. Ja, ich bin Silvan und ich komme aus der Schweiz, wie man hört sehr wahrscheinlich, obwohl ich mir sehr Mühe gebe. Also, es ist nicht Schweizer-Dütsch, was ich spreche, sondern mein bestes Hochdeutsch. Ich bin der Projektleiter von diesem Jutti-Häftli-Projekt, komme aus dem grafischen Bereich, bin selbst Illustrator und deswegen auch Fußballfan. Deswegen passt natürlich diese ganze Jutti-Häftli-Geschichte mit ja, genau in diese Richtung rein.
Es ist nicht ganz so zufällig, dass du das entwickelt hast. Wir werden gleich noch erklären, wie es dazu gekommen ist und außerdem bei uns noch in der Leitung im Nachbarbüro vom Silbernen Peter Brehm.
Hallo, ich bin Peter Brehm, ich bin Freischaffender Illustrator, wohne auf den Luzern und ich hatte die grosse Ehre, dieses Jahr das zweite Mal mitzumachen beim Jutti-Häftli. Das wurde mittels eines Wettbewerbs, wurden da 32 Künstler, Illustratoren, Grafiker ausgewählt, die eine Mannschaft porträtieren durften und ich hatte die große Ehre, das große Vergnügen, das zweite Mal mitzumachen. Letztes Mal bei der EM waren es die Isländer und diesmal die Spanier.
Sehr schön, die Isländer kamen von dir. Toll!
Genau, das war natürlich ein super Lauf.
Absolut, absolut. Also wir werden gleich alles erklären, um was wir hier eigentlich genau sprechen. Vorher möchte ich noch einen kurzen Dank loswerden an Kata, Shadowballer, Jonas, Oeli und Thomas. Alle fünf sind Rasenfunk-Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei und es gibt auch keine exklusiven Inhalte. Wir finanzieren uns allein aus Spenden der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Vielen Dank dafür. Wer uns ebenfalls unterstützen möchte, kann das tun unter rasenfunk.de/.unterstützen. Unterstützenswert ist auch das Tschutti-Häftli, ein Sammelalbum mit Bildchen zur Fußball-WM, nicht nur zur WM, gab es auch schon zu Europameisterschaften. Silvan, erklär uns doch mal, was hat es denn mit dem Tschutti-Häftli auf sich? Was soll denn eigentlich Tschuttis sein?
Ja, Tschutti, also grundsätzlich mal vom Wort her, das kommt aus ursprünglich, wie ich jetzt rausgefunden habe, im Zuge der ganzen Geschichte, habe ich da recherchiert, weil ich das oft gefragt wurde. Tschutten, das bedeutet, im Schweizerdeutschen wird das benutzt wie Bolzen oder Kicken eigentlich, also Fußballspielen. Und es kommt aber ursprünglich aus dem Englischen, weil als der Fußball von England bekanntlich ja dann in die Schweiz kam, auch irgendwann vor über 100 Jahren, ja kam dieses englische Wort Shoot, to shoot, schiessen, wurde dann in der Schweiz als Tschutten interpretiert oder verwendet und so kam eigentlich dieses, also von daher kommt eigentlich dieses Wort Tschutten, also eigentlich gar nicht ursprünglich schweizerisch.
Habe ich auch nicht gewusst, das ist genau.
Ja, ist wirklich witzig.
Das heisst, es ist ein Bolz-Häftli?
Ja, genau. Bolz-Häftli, also eigentlich ein Tschutti-Häftli, so haben wir als Kinder eigentlich auch immer das Panini-Häft genannt. Das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen der Spitzname oder der umgangssprachliche Name vom Panini-Häft und wir haben den jetzt ja sozusagen annektiert für uns.
Gekapert, ja, da werden wir noch darüber sprechen müssen, vor eurer Beziehung zu Panini. Also man kann auch bei euch Bild- Bildli sammeln, Bildchen sammeln von den Fußballern, aber was unterscheidet euch denn von Panini?
Genau, der grosse Unterschied ist, dass wir eben nicht einfach die Fotos der Fußballer abzeigen, dass man nicht die Fotos sammelt, sondern wir haben Künstler wie eben Peter und viele andere engagiert und die Aufgabe gestellt, könnt ihr diese Mannschaft, diese Fußballer, gestalterisch umsetzen. Und diese Illustration kommt dann auf die Bildchen, anstatt die Fotos wie bei Panini und der Rest ist dann aber ziemlich ähnlich. Man kauft ein Tütchen, das sind bei uns zehn Sticker drin und man klebt die ins zugehörige Album, eben ins Tschutti-Häftli, dann möglichst bald dieses Album eben voll zu kriegen.
Und der grosse Unterschied ist, finde ich, Peter, wenn man so ein Häftli durchblättert, wenn es dann endlich mal voll ist oder annähernd voll, Panini war für mich immer so ein bisschen langweilig. Vielleicht bin ich da auch nicht so der Typ für. Und beim Tschutti-Häftli ist einfach jede Seite anders. Das ist das, was mir so gut gefällt.
Ich habe jetzt die Hälfte schon eingeklebt. Ich bin jetzt quasi in der Hauptzeit des Klebens. Das ist viel Arbeit. Das sind ein paar Jahr 520 Kleber, die man einkleben darf. Und ja, das Tolle ist, wenn man dann so eine ganze Seite voll hat und so eine ganze Mannschaft in einem sehr eigenen, ständigen Stil vor sich hat. Und es sind alle wirklich sehr verschieden. Also es hat eben von Grafik über illustrative Sachen, aber auch Montagen und Goulagen. Die Vielfalt ist das Tolle.
Absolut. Jetzt haben wir die schwierige Aufgabe, in einem akustischen Medium etwas Visuelles zu beschreiben. Silvan, kannst du es trotzdem mal irgendwie versuchen? Was erwartet denn, wenn man so ein Tschutti-Häftli in der Hand hat?
Ja, es ist eine kleine Kunstgalerie, durch die man wandert, wenn man die Seiten umblättert. Man kommt in verschiedene Ausstellungsräume, wo jeder Künstler sich seine eigenen Überlegungen gemacht hat. Und da sind Sachen eher wie eine Karikatur, eher lustig. Da sind Sachen doch ziemlich ernsthaft oder heroisch zum Teil. Je nachdem, welche Mannschaft auch ein bisschen. Ich glaube, die Künstler haben dann immer so einen eigenen Ansatz gesucht zum Land, zum Team, ihr Bezug zum Fußball und so und da ist dann eben viel mehr als jetzt einfach was hat der Ronaldo jetzt für eine Frisur dieses Mal auf dem Panini-Bild, sondern da steckt schon ein bisschen mehr dahinter dann.
Stätzig hat die Frage, wie seid ihr denn da drauf gekommen, das zu machen? Steckt ja ein irrer Aufwand dahinter?
Ja, also ein Aufwand, das ist immer das Schöne bei solchen Projekten, dass man den im Moment der Idee nicht so sieht oder sich gar nicht so überlegt zum Glück. Das weiss man ja alles noch nicht, was da alles kommt. Das war die Euro 08 in der Schweiz. Ich habe in Deutschland studiert in Halle an der Saale, in einer schönen Halle an der Saale, das hat mir sehr gut gefallen dort. Dann bin ich zurück in die Schweiz gekommen und da war ja die WM in Deutschland. Ich habe da mitgekriegt, die haben so kulturelle Rahmenprogramme auch gehabt, von offizieller Seite unterstützt, zum Beispiel an der Burg Halle, wo ich studiert habe. Da gab es so ein Projekt und da habe ich dann gedacht, jetzt ist die Euro in der Schweiz und die haben auch so kulturelle Sachen geplant gehabt. Ich habe mich darauf auch gefreut und umso näher ging es da immer nur um Sponsoring und ob man jetzt noch in welcher Kneipe verkaufen kann vor dem Stadion und solche Dinge. Dieses Kulturprogramm wurde dann irgendwie gecancelt. Das offizielle. Es gab damals schon das Jutti-Häftchen, aber das war mehr so ein Fan-Scene. Vier oder fünf Nummern, kleiner als elf Freunde zum Beispiel, aber ein bisschen ähnlich von der Thematik und vom Ansatz und vom Blick auf Fußball. Wir haben dann gedacht, da müssen wir jetzt was machen, wenn die das offizielle Kulturprogramm canzeln, dann machen wir jetzt halt so was ganz Kleines für uns hier. Das lag dann ein bisschen auf der Hand als Illustrator, Grafiker, dass man jetzt halt dieses Sammelheft irgendwie mal versucht, schön zu machen oder schöner, weil die Erinnerungen an Panini, die sind schön als Kind, war das immer toll. Ich habe dann immer mal auch wieder gekauft und so ein bisschen versucht, dieses Sammeln zu kriegen, aber ich habe dann einfach so grafisch – ne, also das war es dann nicht mehr – jetzt bei Panini und ja, da haben wir irgendwie mal beim Bier abends diese Idee gehabt und dann gedacht, ok, jetzt fragen wir mal ein paar Kollegen, die zeichnen und malen, ob die Bock haben.
Aber kann man sowas denn einfach mal so machen?
Das ging damals irgendwie, also das hat sich dann so ergeben. Ich habe ein paar Leute gefragt und auch Studienkollegen angeschrieben und also es ging nicht in eine Woche und da hatten wir die 16 Zeichner, die es braucht damals, waren 16 Teams, hatten wir ja in einer Woche zusammen, also ja und wir haben gesagt, ihr kriegt kein Geld dafür, wir haben keine Ahnung, wie wir das finanzieren, wir machen jetzt einfach mal und wir hatten so ein bisschen Geld vom Tutti-Häftli-Magazin, das hat gerade so für den ersten Druck gereicht und ja, wir haben noch Sponsoren gesucht, so Kneipe nie aus Luzern, haben wir gefragt, ja zeichnen euer Logo dann auf die Seite im Heft, gibt ihr uns irgendwie 300 Franken oder sowas und so ging das dann, ja.
Aber wie ist denn das rechtlich, dürft ihr denn einfach so die Sportler malen, muss man da gucken, dass es besonders künstlerisch ist oder bringe ich dich jetzt komplett in Bedrängnis, ist der Peter überhaupt noch da, wahrscheinlich schon weggerannt?
Ja, ich habe auch vieles nicht gewusst, das ist sehr vornhaut für mich.
Ja eben, Peter ist jetzt das letzte Mal so zum ersten Mal richtig eingetaucht, aber ja, die Rechtsfrage, die begleitet uns immer wieder. Wir haben bei uns im Verein auch einen Juristen, ich habe auch schon mit Juristen intensiv darüber gesprochen und es gibt halt so die sehr hochgewichtete Kunstfreiheit. Und da wir ein Kunstprojekt sind und auch bleiben und das auch, denke ich, mal falls es so weit käme, vor Gericht belegen können und da wir auch kein Profit machen, also in dem Sinne nicht gewinnorientiert sind, weil wenn wir eine Bilanz ausrechnen, also wenn wir ausrechnen, was alles gearbeitet wird und wie viel Geld am Schluss reinkommt, dann ja, könnten wir da auch leicht nachweisen, dass es nicht gewinnorientiert ist. Und aus dem Grund, denke ich, gab es bis jetzt noch keinen Kläger und…
Aber was könnte dann eine Lücke sein, also die Bildrechte letztendlich oder…
Ja, also erstens, wir verwenden natürlich auch keine Namen wie FIFA oder die ganzen Verbandslogos und so, das verwenden wir bewusst nicht. Das ist ja auch nicht spannend. Wir wollen lieber eigene Logos zeichnen lassen für die Mannschaften und den Künstlern. Grundsätzlich, wenn du mit einer berühmten Person oder mit einer bekannten Person, die benutzt auf irgendeine Art, um Geld damit zu verdienen, auf deren Kosten sozusagen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie…
Also es geht oft um die Verfremdung von einem Bild, dass du einen aus dem Internet hast. Oder wenn das eine eigene Intention drin ist und eine Verfremdung, dann bist du geschützt durch die Künstlerfreiheit.
Ja, da weisst du wahrscheinlich sogar noch besser als Illustrator, wo da die Grenzen sind. Ich glaube, sobald man sagen kann, das ist jetzt ein eigenständiges Kunstwerk in künstlerischem Wert, dann ist das auch geschützt durch diese Kunstfreiheit.
Was auch speziell ist, weil man doch noch oft im Context, wenn man über das Tutti-Häufchen spricht, dann fällt da doch noch oft das Wort Panini oder das ist vielleicht noch Delikat. Dieser Vergleich findet halt ziemlich oft statt.
Hat sich denn mal jemand von Panini bei euch gemeldet, Silvan?
Nein, direkt Panini nicht. Aber es gibt eine lustige Geschichte da rund um Panini, weil wir drucken ja auch in Italien. Und das ist eben nicht die Panini-Druckerei, sondern das ist eine andere Druckerei. Aber der Chef dieser Druckerei, der heisst Panini. Im Album 14, da haben wir so ein bisschen als ironische Hommage an die Panini-Brüder. Das waren ja vier Brüder. Da haben wir ein Vierfachsammelbild von den Panini-Brüdern drin gehabt. Als wir das drucken ließen, habe ich plötzlich eine Mail von der Projektleiterin gekriegt, ob wir ihnen nicht unbedingt ein paar Alben und Sticker schicken können, weil ihr Chef, der Herr Panini, sei ein Sohn von einem dieser vier Panini-Brüder. Die Panini haben das ja verkauft an Marvel, wenn ich mich nicht irre. Der ganze Panini-Verlag. Der Sohn ist jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr bei der Panini-Gruppe dabei, sondern hat sich eine eigene Assis-Chef von einer anderen Druckerei, die aber auch Sammelbilder machen. Und die drucken zum Beispiel eben auch unsere Bilder. Der hat sich auf jeden Fall sehr gefreut und hat dann gesagt, mein Vater ist da auf dem Sammelbild, ich möchte gerne Sticker und Alben haben und so. Aber so jetzt von der offiziellen Panini-Seite, da haben wir noch nie was gehört bis jetzt.
Ist ja wahrscheinlich auch besser, willst du es jetzt auch nicht beschreiben. Aber jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, dass ihr nicht profitorientiert seid, und es landen ja auch nicht alle Gewinne bei euch. Kannst du mal kurz beschreiben, wie seid ihr da denn organisiert und was passiert mit dem Geld, das die Leute ja dafür bezahlen, dass sie diese Bildchen sammeln können?
Genau, also ja, das Geld ist erstens mal so fix gehen, 10 Rappen pro verkaufte Tüte gehen an Terdesarm Schweiz. Das ist eine Organisation, die setzt sich ein, um vor allem Jugendliche, die benachteiligt sind in Ländern wie Südamerika oder Afrika, zu setzen, die sich einmachen zu Projekten, unter anderem mit Fußball, um die Kinder von der Strasse zu holen, um die Jugendlichen da in ein bisschen geregeltere Ausbildungen zu bringen. Und Fußball ist da natürlich ein Türöffner dafür. Das ist von dem her ein toller Bezug, den wir gesucht haben, und den wir seit, glaube ich, 2014 auch unterstützen. Das ist der gute Zweck, sage ich jetzt mal. Auch heute ist es noch so, dass die Künstler das kostenlos machen. Also in dem Sinne, wir sagen ja, wir können nicht garantieren, dass ihr da was dafür kriegt. Und wenn ihr was kriegt, dann wird das auch kein wirklicher üblicher Illustratorenlohn sein, sondern das geht dann mehr Richtung Spesenentschädigung. Und ein Teil des Gewinns, je nachdem, wie es läuft, werden wir eben dann unter den Künstlern aufteilen. Ja, und der ganze Rest, der wird dann eigentlich in unserem Verein verwendet, um eben die nächste Ausgabe zu planen, um unsere Ateliermiete hier, wo wir die ganzen Archivbilder, das wachsende Archiv, sag ich jetzt mal, haben und so weiter. Also für so laufende Kosten und für das nächste Album wird das verwendet, genau.
Hast du mal ausgerechnet, bei Panini muss man ja unglaubliche Summen investieren, inzwischen um ein ganzes Album voll zu bekommen. Hast du mal ausgerechnet, wie viel das bei euch ist?
Ja, es ist eben relativ kompliziert. Also wenn ich jetzt nur Tüten kaufe, ohne zu tauschen, da haben wir mal so einen Mathematiker, der uns mal eine extrem komplizierte Formel aufgeschrieben hat, und dann wird es extrem teuer. Generell, bei Panini, wenn man so eine Box kauft, bei uns sind da 50 Tüten drin, dann hat man meistens, bis auf 30 bis 40 Bilder, hat man da schon mal alle. Da hat man gegen 500, dann gibt es verschiedene, und den Rest, wenn man tauscht, kostet das vielleicht nochmal, weiß auch nicht. Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, mit 80 Schweizer Franken, wenn man fleißig tauscht, sollte man eigentlich das Album voll kriegen.
Also deutlich günstiger als Panini. Wir haben ja auch gehört, dass das bewusst gemacht ist. Das hast du ja in dem O-Ton, den ich ins Intro geschnitten habe, gesagt, dass es eine bewusste Entscheidung gegen den Kommerz im Fußball war.
Ja, genau. Wir machen das ja alles seit zehn Jahren nicht wegen dem Geld. Weil sonst verdient haben wir daran eigentlich noch nichts. Wirklich sind wir nicht reich geworden. Und damit wollen wir auch zeigen, dass man auch Sachen machen kann, ohne dass es jetzt nur ums Geld geht und dass dann manchmal sogar die Qualität oder die Begeisterung dahinter eben auch spürbar ist. Und vielleicht gerade eben, weil es nicht ums Geld geht, die Sache sogar noch schöner wird.
Und Peter, war das für dich mal ein Thema? Weil du musst ja viel Arbeit in deine Illustration reinstecken. Hast du einen aufwendigen Illustrationsstil und kriegst dafür dann nichts.
Hast du es gesehen?
Ja, na klar, ich gehe auf die Islander, die du im letzten Jahr gemacht hast.
Ja, also gerade bei Peter habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen natürlich. Nein, ich muss sagen, weil er so viel arbeitet und fast nichts kriegt von uns.
Ja, aber ich muss schon darauf bestehen, es war alles in allem, als ich vor zwei Jahren das erste Mal mitgemacht habe, es war sehr lukrativ eigentlich, weil, nur schon deshalb, dein Name wird gesehen. Ich hatte dann auch einige Folgeaufträge aufgrund dessen. Ich bin noch sehr am Anfang so meiner Karriere, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Sylvan hat uns noch ein Wochenende nach Paris eingeladen und es gab ein Crowdfunding, das das Deal sehr schnell erreicht war, wo der Gewinn aufgeteilt wurde auf die Künstler. Und da ich primär als Analog arbeite, konnte ich auch noch gut die Hälfte der Originale verkaufen, zu einem guten Preis. Also alles in allem hat mich das sehr viel weitergebracht. Da bin ich jetzt froh. Na, auf jeden Fall. Ich würde sagen, ohne Studio-Hälfte wäre ich noch nicht halb so weit.
Ja, das ist natürlich toll, weil das ist mit dem Grund, mit dem Ziel, auch bei uns eine Plattform zu sein. Wenn ich das jetzt so höre, ja, das ist natürlich super.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Du bist sichtbar. Ich konnte sogar in Island noch Postgarten verkaufen. Ich habe einen Freund geschickt, der in Reykjavík wohnt. Ich habe dann so ein schönes Postgarten-Set gemacht. Und die hatten da ein paar Q-Werts im Kiosk gegeben.
Schön zu hören. Da stellt sich dann für mich ein bisschen die Frage, wie viele Exemplare von Judy Heftley verkauft ihr denn inzwischen? Das hört sich ja so an, als wäre das aus dieser Schnaps-Idee im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes eine größere Nummer geworden.
Ja, das ist jetzt schon die sechste Ausgabe. Und das ist schon immer gewachsen. Also wir hatten natürlich eben das Wachstum, ich würde jetzt immer noch behaupten, das ist ein organisches Wachstum. Wir haben das auch nie bewusst forciert. Wir haben auch gar nicht die Kapazität dazu und die Ressourcen. Aber wir haben immer darauf geachtet, dass da Partner mit an Bord kommen, die wir unterstützen können. Also unser deutscher Vertriebspartner zum Beispiel, neben dem, was an Teredes am Schweiz geht, spendet er von sich aus noch etwas an Viva Con Aqua, weil er aus diesem Umfeld kommt und die Leute kennt dort. Das ist dann so eine Sache, wo wir sagen, mit euch machen wir das jetzt. Die geben jetzt ziemlich Gas in Deutschland, mit elf Freunden die Kooperation. Es gibt es mittlerweile auch an vielen Kiosken zu kaufen. Das ist dann so eine Frage, eine Schrittrichtung, Kommerzialisierung. Aber ich denke, solange das eben mit Partnern passiert, die letztendlich auch unsere Idee weitertragen, ist das ja toll, wenn die Plattform immer grösser wird für die Künstler.
Und wie viele Exemplare habt ihr produziert?
Genau, wir haben jetzt diese Zahl, wirklich eine neue Rekordzahl von 750.000 Stickertüten. Also wenn man das in Bildschirmen ausrechnet, werden das 7, 5 Millionen Bildchen und um die 10.000 bis 15.000 Alpen. Aber wenn man jetzt vergleicht mit Panini, ich denke mal, 10 Minuten nach Verkaufsstart haben sie uns da schon übertroffen.
Ja, aber halt mit welcher Art Produkt, das ist ja letztlich die Frage.
Genau, genau.
Muss ja auch jeder für sich selbst bewerten. Erklär doch mal, was hat es mit den 523 Maradonna auf sich?
Das war unser Wettbewerb. Also wir machen jetzt, eben am Anfang habe ich ja gesagt, wir haben so die paar Kumpel aus dem Umfeld, Kamilitonen oder Studienfreunde oder so gefragt, willst du mal zeichnen? Das ging eigentlich immer sehr gut so, aber irgendwann haben wir auch gedacht, ja, jetzt melden sich plötzlich mehr Leute, jetzt müssen wir da anfangen auszusortieren, was für Kriterien machen wir da? Und dann haben wir überlegt, dann machen wir aber gleich jetzt einen richtigen Wettbewerb. Und wir haben dann 2014 Brasilien passenderweise in den Pelé zeichnen lassen zum ersten Mal. Und jetzt eben für das aktuelle Album war die Aufgabe des Wettbewerbs den Maradona zu zeichnen. Und ja, dann haben wir auch da einen neuen Rekord eigentlich erzielt von Eingaben. Wir wurden wirklich regelrecht überflutet von Maradonas und tollen Umsetzungen. Du hast die Zahl gesagt, ich glaube 523. Genau, genau. Und dann eben auch aus aller Welt. Also es war wirklich China, USA, Russland, ganz viele. Iran auch ganz viele, lustigerweise. Also logischerweise auch, weil die ja auch an der WM dabei sind.
Aber weisst du das? Du hast dann schon, das hat ja auch viele aus Russland Einsendungen gehabt. Du hast das schon da irgendwie gepusht auf gewissen Konälen oder so.
Also gut, wir hatten die Ausschreibung auf Russisch übersetzen lassen, von einer Freundin von mir, die Russisch kann. Und das ist eben schon toll, diese Plattformen für Gestaltungswettbewerbe, die es heutzutage im Netz gibt, da postest du das irgendwo und dann kommst du eben aus Indien, Wettbewerbseingaben und das hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, glaube ich jetzt mal, dass wir haben relativ, also einerseits Maradona ist sehr bekannt, das war ja auch die Idee, deswegen haben wir jetzt auch ihn diesmal gewählt und zusätzlich ist auch unser doch eher bescheidenes Preisgeld, sage ich jetzt mal für unsere Verhältnisse von, ich glaube für den ersten gab es glaube ich 300 Euro oder sowas pro Sieger, das ist natürlich dann für jemanden, der in Russland lebt oder in Indien, ist das natürlich dann schon vielleicht ein zusätzlicher Anreiz eben bei diesem Wettbewerb mitzumachen.
Und dann hat jeder Künstler einen Diego Maradona in seinem Stil eingereicht, das heisst, ihr hattet 523 Künstler, die da teilgenommen haben. Wie wählt man da denn aus, das stelle ich mir wahnsinnig schwierig vor. Das hat ja auch viel mit Geschmack zu tun.
Das hat extrem viel mit Geschmack zu tun und ich meine klar, man kann vielleicht sage ich jetzt mal, ein Maximum, ein Fünftel kannst du vielleicht davon wirklich mal sagen, ok, das ist qualitativ, reicht das nicht, das ist vielleicht nur zwei Photoshop-Filter drüber, über ein Foto oder sowas, das hat es auch dabei. Aber selbst wenn du die alle dann mal aussortierst, dann hast du echt letztendlich 300 Bilder, sage ich jetzt mal, die könnte man alle nehmen. Den würde ich jetzt allen zutrauen, dass sie eine gute Mannschaft umsetzen können oder so. Ja, deswegen haben wir eben das Delegiert an den Jury.
Das ist vor der Entscheidung schwierig.
Genau.
Und wer sitzt dann in dieser Jury? Ein Äffchen mit einem Würfelbecher und eine Zimmerpflanze?
Genau. Also es wäre vielleicht auch, ich weiss nicht, wie es dann rausgekommen wäre. Nein, wir haben uns auch bei der Jury ein bisschen überlegt, wir wollen ein Heft machen, dass dann nicht irgendwann einfach nur, wie soll ich sagen, Gestalt herkommt, sondern da soll auch für jeden etwas dabei sein. Deswegen haben wir eine zehnköpfige Jury zusammengestellt, wo wir immer so einen Versuch, einen Mix zwischen Leuten, die wirklich von Kunst oder Gestaltung eine Ahnung haben, weil sie aus dem Bereich kommen. Und die andere Hälfte, da nehmen wir halt so ein bisschen mehr oder weniger prominente Leute, die was mit dem Thema zu tun haben oder mit Fußball. Also Fußball oder jetzt in diesem Fall Russland auch. Und da hatten wir jetzt zum Beispiel die Nadia Tolonkova. Ich kann den Namen leider. Also sagen wir Nadia von Pussy Riot. Genau, das geht einfacher. Die hat zum Beispiel ein Bild ausgewählt und die haben dann alle auch eine Shortlist gemacht. Und aus dieser Shortlist haben wir von Judy Hefty dann versucht, möglichst eben auch verschiedene Stile auszuwählen. Es gibt natürlich dann ähnliche Stile, Malerei zum Beispiel, realistische. Da gab es ganz viele. Und da wollten wir dann nicht, dass zu viele ähnliche Stile dabei sind.
Wie viele Künstler sind denn dann jetzt im Heft gelandet? Also wie viele Peter Brems gibts denn noch?
Es gibt insgesamt pro Team, pro Mannschaft, eine. Und das sind dann 32.
32 aus über 500 Einsendungen. Peter, da bist du ein mit Glück gesegneter.
Sehr spekulativ, ich habe mich schon beim Wettbewerbsbeitrag enorm ins Zeug gelegt, weil ich wusste, erstmal musst du mal reinkommen.
Ja, bei Peter denke ich immer, mein Gott, wenn ich seine Wettbewerbs-Einsendung sehe, denke ich so, oh Peter, was hast du dir hier wieder aufgehasst? Weil du musst ja dann jetzt nicht nur den einen machen, sondern dann eben eine ganze Mannschaft.
Ja, es ist eben nicht nur Arbeit, es ist eben auch Leidenschaft.
Ja, das spürt man auch. Das ist auch toll. Ich sage jetzt mal, wenn ich vorher gesagt habe, 10% oder so kann man aussortieren, dann gibt es auch so ein paar, die wirklich herausstechen. Und das sage ich jetzt nicht nur, weil du hier bist, Peter, aber dein Maradona hat auf jeden Fall dazu gehört, wo ich eigentlich schon wusste, dass der irgendwie ausgewählt wird. Du hast da so viele kleine Sachen eingebaut im Stil von Albrecht Dürer und so kleine Sachen zu Maradona und seinen Vergangenheiten. Ich weiss gar nicht, vielleicht kannst du selber noch ein bisschen sagen, was du da alle… War es ein Gaucho?
Ja, es war sehr schwierig, das zu beschreiben. Genau, bei Maradona ist es toll, wenn du den googlst, dann hast du jede Dekade einen völlig anderen Menschen. Also eine sehr viele Persönlichkeiten, eine vorsettenreiche Persönlichkeit, nur schon visuell. Und bei mir gibt es jetzt wirklich so ein tolles Bild, als er dann WM14, also Argentinien trainiert hat, hat er sich dann extrem wieder rausgeputzt, hat ihn sehr gepflegt, ausgeschaut. Und bei mir ist es jetzt aber so ein leicht verbitterter alter Herr, King in the Castle, so als Gaucho in einem Schloss mit viele Hinten auf seine Vergangenheit.
Das Spiegelchen auf dem Tisch vor ihm.
Das wollte ich nicht allzu prominent machen.
Aber es war da, wir haben es gesehen.
Wird da ein gewisser Narzissmus unterstellt oder ist der Spiegel für andere Tätigkeiten da?
Ja, für andere Sachen.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob es die Möglichkeit gibt, Peter, dass ich das Bild vielleicht in dieser Folge einbette, dann könnten die Hörerinnen und Hörer das mal gucken.
Auf jeden Ball kann ich dir schicken, ja.
Das wäre super. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr könnt es dann auf rasenfunk.de slash tribünengespräch in der Folge hier sehen. Dann wissen auch alle, welcher Aufwand dahintersteckt. Wie lange dauert es denn dann, so eine komplette Mannschaft zu machen? Und wer wählt eigentlich aus, welche Spieler da dann illustriert werden? Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema.
Also ich glaube, ich habe einen Spezialisten, der die Mannschaft auch schon.
Genau, also wir haben unser grösster Fußballkennner, der Chrigou, der das zusammen mit ein paar Leuten macht, die er kennt, die eben auch so ich sage jetzt mal Fußball-Experten sind oder sich sehr intensiv beschäftigen. Und die versuchen dann da, es ist schwierig, wir müssen das im November machen, die Liste nach der Quali, und da muss man elf Leute auf den Platz stellen eigentlich schon. Und da gibt es natürlich, also es gab zum Beispiel den Balotelli, den wir nicht dabei hatten, also da so gross aufgetrumpft hat. Einmal haben wir Ribery vergessen, aber das war eher irgendwie ein Übertragungsfehler, glaube ich.
Ja, bei Islanden war es ja auch vor zwei Jahren dieser Bärtige, der war noch nicht dabei.
Ja, aber wir hatten auch schon Brasilien 14, ich glaube die Startelf von Brasilien im ersten Spiel, die war eins zu eins unsere Elf im Jutti-Heftli. Also da habe ich dann schon gedacht, ob das Jutti-Heftli vielleicht auch dort gelesen wird. Gelesen wird, in der Kabine.
Also das muss man eben dazu sagen, im Jutti-Heftli gibt es da nicht den kompletten Kader, sondern eben elf Spielerporträts und ich glaube noch ein Porträt immer vom Künstler selbst, der sich dann selbst stellt.
Genau, also Trainer haben wir auch dabei, das ist glaube ich Panini auch nicht, wenn ich mich nicht irre. Und der Künstler natürlich, der gehört da auch bei uns auch zum Team, also der ist gleich berechtigt.
Und ein Wappen, oder so ein Verbandswappen.
Ja, so ein Landeswappen.
Das heisst, es sind dann 14 Sticker pro Mannschaft und wie lange hast du jetzt dann dafür gebraucht, Peter?
Ja, das ist lustigerweise oft, wenn ich Arbeiten von mir präsentiere, oft die erste Frage, die die Leute stellen.
Ja, weil du so einen aufwendigen Stil hast. Also die Leute werden ja dann sehen, dass du auf die Seite bist.
Ich kann es natürlich nachvollziehen, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe mir etwa eineinhalb Monate Zeit genommen. Es ist dann schwierig, was viel Zeit braucht, ist die Komposition, die Bildrecherche. Ich habe damit Gemälde aus dem 17. Jahrhundert gearbeitet, die auswählen, die Komposition machen. Und dann die Ausführung hatte ich eigentlich selten länger als eineinhalb Tage. Ich habe natürlich noch andere Legimitationen, wieso ich das so aufwendig gemacht habe. Ich rechne damit, dass ich ein, zwei Originale verkaufen kann. Ich wollte mir dieses Material ein bisschen aneignen, so eine spezielle Weisserschabkarton nennt sich das. Und trotzdem wusste ich, dass ich in einer Monatsfrist fertig werden muss. Das ging dann ganz gut.
Aber hast du in diesem Monat dann noch etwas anderes machen können?
Nein, da habe ich mir wirklich Zeit genommen dafür. Ich bin freischaffender Illustrator. Ich bin froh, wenn ich eine ausgefüllte Arbeitswoche habe. Absolut, auf jeden Fall. Ich rechne damit, dass ich die Originale verkaufen kann. Und dann lohnt es sich.
Wie groß sind denn die Originale? Du wusstest ja kaum, wie viele Zentimeter das sein wird. 4 auf 8 Zentimeter in Arbeit.
4, 7 auf 8, 5.
Guck mal, ist das so schlecht?
Nein, die Originale sind 21 x 15.
Dann wird es von euch noch mal eingescannt, oder wie macht ihr das?
Ja, wir kriegen das dann meistens von Künstlern schon eingescannt. Dann können sie die auch so einstellen.
Das ist wirklich heiklig, doch es ist immer ein bisschen ein Zittern, ob die Reproduktion so gut kommt. Aber sie haben wirklich ein gutes Druckverfahren. Ich bin enorm zufrieden wieder mit den Stickern. Super, ja.
Wahnsinn. Und dann hat man wirklich alle Stile mit dabei. Diesmal ist mir besonders hängen geblieben eine Outline-Technik aus Pulver. Da sieht man auf den ersten Blick gar nicht, dass das richtig einfach nur Pulver ist und nicht...
Aber Panna-Mau meinst du, glaube ich, ne?
Genau, ich habe ja meine Tütchen noch nicht aufgemacht. Sie liegen zwar hier neben mir, aber ich dosiere das ehrlich gesagt immer. Ich mache immer zwei, drei Tütchen auf und dann wird ein Abend lang geklebt und dann wieder ein bisschen aufgemacht. Ich habe es aber bei euch auf der Seite gesehen, wo ihr die entsprechenden Maradona-Bilder zum Teil mit dabei habt.
Ah, Maradona aus Kokain.
Ah, das Pulver meinst du. Ja, genau. Der Künstler hat gedacht, das geht natürlich für Panama. Das geht jetzt nicht die Idee mit dem Pulver. Die hat jetzt vor allem bei Maradona gepasst. Er war dann glaube ich tatsächlich gerade irgendwo im Urlaub. Also im Urlaub, sondern aus Zeit. Am Strand zumindest. Und dort hat er dann gedacht, jetzt mache ich die Panamas aus Sand. Und er hat dann verschiedenfarbigen Sand genommen. Panama ist jetzt auch so mit so Linien gestreut, aber aus Sand.
Ja und der Hintergrund sind ja die Panama Papers, oder? Also das habe ich im Playlist erst vorgestern gemerkt. Aber es sind ja so verschiedene Papiere. Das sind sehr charakteristische Papiere zu Oberflächen. Und das sind natürlich die Panama Papers.
Ich habe noch gedacht, es kommt jetzt vielleicht eine Anspielung auf die ganze Geschichte bei Panama. Aber ja, es ist sehr subtil dann. Im Vordergrund ist der Sand natürlich.
Wie kommt denn das dann zustande? Welcher Künstler welches Land macht?
Manchmal ist es ganz klar, dass jemand, wir haben einen Künstler aus dem Iran, der wollte dann den Iran machen und das hat auch Sinn gemacht, klar. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Schweizer, zum Beispiel. Da wollen die meisten Schweizer, die möchten, dann gerne die Schweiz machen. Oder Deutschland ist auch sehr beliebt, natürlich. Die Künstler konnten, glaube ich, fünf, ich weiss gar nicht mehr, so eine Top-5 reinreichen.
Genau, man konnte eine Liste machen, Referenzen.
So von eins bis fünf und dann haben wir geschaut, geht es irgendwie auf, dass mindestens jeder einer dieser fünf kriegt. Und dann vielleicht noch, wenn jemand eben aus dem Land stammt, hat er dann Vorrang vor dem anderen. Oder man konnte eine Begründung schreiben, warum man jetzt welches Land möchte. Und da haben wir versucht, das so ein bisschen zu berücksichtigen. Aber manchmal, ich glaube, diesmal auch am Schluss, müssen wir dann zwei oder drei einfach zuteilen, zulosen sozusagen und sagen, ok, für euch hat es jetzt nicht geklappt, dass ihr einen dieser fünf Top-Teams kriegt. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal einen italienischen Künstler dabei. Das ist leider nicht geklappt. Der hat dann Portugal gekriegt.
Immerhin ein Europameister durfte er dann machen. Ihr habt hinten drin im Heft noch die Sektion Under 13. Was ist denn damit gemeint?
Genau, das ist auch ein Teil vom Wettbewerb. Wir haben gedacht, wir müssten langsam ein bisschen Nahrung betreiben und haben dann so einen Wettbewerb für Unter 13-Jährige gemacht. Dort war es nicht das Ziel, dass sie eben Maradona zeigten, sondern einfach ein Portrait von ihrem Lieblingsfußballer. Es gab sogar auch Lieblingsfußballerinnen, die da gezeichnet wurden. Leider hat es von denen jetzt keine Insektivität geschafft, aber es gibt da jetzt einfach eine Top 11 von Kinderzeichnungen. Die Kinder sind zwischen 5 und 13 Jahren und die haben da auch mit ihrem ganz eigenen Stil, wirklich zum Zeit tolle – Thomas Müller finde ich toll zum Beispiel – gemacht.
Ich finde das sehr geschickt, diese Alterslimite, weil man sagt, nach 12, 13, 14 Jahren werden die Kids, es muss dann echt aussehen oder so, die Zeichnungen oder so. Man sagt so, dann nimmt das Level von den Kinderzeichnungen rapide ab, weil sie plötzlich diesen Realitätsanspruch haben und halt so diese Kids, also diese Zeichnungen, die sind extrem frei und super.
Und ja, das wird dann echt zum Teil treffen die Spieler dann besser, so in ihrem Kern habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, wenn die dann wirklich so einfach drauf los mal einzeichnen. Genau, ja und das ist, finde ich, auch eine tolle Sache. Natürlich eben, welches Kind freut sich nicht, wenn es sein eigenes Fußballbildchen dann einkommt.
Ja, total. Welcher Lieblingsspieler war da bei den Kinderzeichnungen mit dabei?
Was gab es da? Es gab natürlich den Ronaldo. Es gab – das ist jetzt eine gute Frage, da müsste ich jetzt hier ein Album schnell konsultieren.
Nee, nee, ich meinte jetzt auch gar nicht. Also ich meinte, wer wurde am häufigsten eingeschickt? Das meinte ich. Also ich habe das Album ja vor mir, wir haben noch Obermeer Young, Vidal, Alaphore. Neymar gleich zweimal sehe ich.
Neymar zweimal, genau. Zuerst habe ich gedacht, ja, jetzt kommt irgendwie 20, 30 Mal Ronaldo. Aber das war dann tatsächlich gar nicht so eben. Ich glaube, wir haben ja wirklich nicht danach ausgewählt, welchen Spieler die zeichnen, sondern nach dem Aussehen. Wenn jetzt alle Ronaldo toll gewesen wären, hätten wir die alle ins Heft gemacht. Aber es war wirklich eine breite Auswahl. Ähnlich breit, wie das im Heft jetzt ist. Das ist da eben von Müller, Vidal, Ibala, Hamsik.
Tolle Auswahl. Und im Kontrast dazu sind die ersten vier Bildchen, die Bildchen Nummer eins bis vier, sind die FIFA-Statuten. Und daneben prangt ein Auszug aus den FIFA-Statuten betreffend die Menschenrechte. Wie kam denn das ins Album? Das hat doch bestimmt einen Hintersinn.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Durch die Arbeit mit TV, die ich schon erwähnt habe, 2014 haben wir uns so ein bisschen angefangen, eben immer so ein Thema auch zu geben. 2014 hieß die Sektion noch – also dieser Teil hieß The Dark Side, glaube ich. Da haben wir aufgezeigt, was für Probleme ins Land kommen mit so einem grossen Turnier.
Und es war ein Wunder, dass ihr da mit einer Doppelseite ausgekommen seid.
Ja, das ist natürlich… Und jetzt lustiger oder nicht unbedingt lustig, aber bei Russland ist das natürlich ein schwieriges Thema. Wir haben dann einfach gesagt, wir wollen jetzt aber auch nicht irgendwie in Russland Bashing machen, weil grundsätzlich kann man ja beim Fußball allgemein mal schauen, so Menschenrechte, wie sitzen da. Und jetzt diesen Auszug aus den FIFA-Statuten nimmt und sagt, dass da steht ja eben, dass keine Menschen aufgrund der Ethnie, der Herkunft, des Geschlechts, der sexuellen Ausrichtung, das steht jetzt da nicht drin, aber es ist auch da drin, in den Statuten diskriminiert werden darf. Und wenn man dann den Fußball an sich anschaut, dann ist der Fußball da schon noch menschenrechtstechnisch zum Teil ganz stark hinternacht in diesem, nicht nur in Russland.
Nicht nur im Fussballplatz, das ist eigentlich nicht primär. Ja, in den Stadien auch. Der ganze Aufbau einer WM.
Das auch, natürlich. Wir haben dann zusammen mit dem Terdesom und Children Win, dieser Dachorganisation, überlegt, was wollen wir eben machen. Und dann haben wir gedacht, die haben gesagt, schaut euch mal die Statuten an. Und dann war für uns plötzlich klar, okay, wir bringen doch einfach mal diese Statuten, die kann dann jeder selbst durchlesen und sich Gedanken machen dazu vielleicht. Weil da steht ja auch, dass wenn diese Menschenrechte nicht geachtet wird, dass man da ausgeschlossen wird aus der Organisation und solche Dinge. Und ja, also ich glaube, da muss man gar nicht mehr so viel dazu sagen. Aber ich finde dann toll, wie die russische Designerin, die das Album gemacht hat, eben das auch grafisch umgesetzt hat. Also man kann das ja kaum lesen dann, so wie mit so Zensurbalken durchgestrichen ein bisschen. Und ja, finde ich dann eben auch eine tolle Umsetzung davon.
Ja, es ist ein optischer Störer. Also ich habe auch das Album aufgemacht und dachte mir, Huch, haben sie sich da verdruckt und dann fängt man an den Text zu lesen und dann dämmert einem so langsam, das wird wahrscheinlich Absicht sein, dass das nur noch schwierig zu erkennen ist oder bei genauem Hinsehenden. Das ist ja dann auch die Metaebene, die so ein bisschen mitgeliefert werden soll. Kriegt ihr denn da auch Rückmeldung von den Künstlern, wenn ihr jetzt so Einreichungen aus aller Welt habt, wie die den Fußball sehen und das, was da bei so einer WM passiert, da sind ja bestimmt auch viele politisch aktive Künstler mit dabei.
So direkt eigentlich? Beim Wettbewerb kriegen wir halt vor allem diese Bilder, aber da haben wir jetzt nicht eine Rückmeldung in dem Sinne auf diese Geschichte. Aber das wäre sehr wahrscheinlich, ja, das ist jetzt noch eine spannende Frage, weil das auch mal spannend wäre, die Künstler auch das zu fragen. Gerade die Künstler, die international sind, wie sie den Fußball sehen oder diese Thematik ein bisschen, ja.
Gibt es denn irgendwie einen Austausch der Künstler untereinander, Peter, oder passiert das wenn dann zufällig?
Ja, es war jetzt am Freitag diese große Release-Party hier in Luzern. Und ja, dann hatten wir danach schon ein paar Facebook-Freunde mehr. Man trifft die Leute, ich habe mich jetzt leider nicht so sehr mit den – Silvan hat da ein paar Russen eingeflogen, die eine Mannschaft gemacht haben. Und ich habe jetzt leider nicht so Gelegenheit, ich hätte gerne ein paar von diesen kennen gelernt. Aber sonst auf jeden Fall. Es sind ja auch viele Schweizer jetzt dabei und dann lernt man wieder neue Szenes kennen.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Am Freitag haben wir gesagt, wir laden jetzt alle ein und bezahlen auch die Reise für die Leute aus Russland. Und da sind ein paar gekommen. Ich war da natürlich auch viel Trubel und so am Abend. Ich habe eben viel zu wenig gesprochen mit diesen Leuten. Aber das ist eigentlich ein guter Punkt. Ich glaube, wenn die Leute sich hier schon treffen zu einem Release, müsste man vielleicht auch den Tag zusammen verbringen oder irgendwie noch zusammen was essen gehen, dass das nicht so nur an der Party, wo es dann so drunter und drüber geht. Ich glaube, die ganze Vernetzung, das wäre schon spannend, wenn man das noch ein bisschen vertiefen könnte.
Ich fand auf jeden Fall das Interview mit der russischen Grafkrin, die das Heft gemacht hat, das fand ich sehr interessant.
Das heisst, das ganze Design kommt dann von einer von ein und derselben Person?
Genau, das ist zum ersten Mal auch. Das ist auch eine Neuheit sozusagen. Vorher, sage ich jetzt mal, war das Design des Albums immer so ein bisschen stiefmütterlich. Also das wurde dann halt noch so auch noch gemacht. Und es ist ja auch so, dass das nicht so ein auffälliges Design sein darf, dass das die Dicke konkurrenziert. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt diese Aufgabe einer russischen Grafikerin gegeben, der Natascha Agapova aus Moskau. Die hat da ein Designstudio. Und ja, ich finde, die hat das wirklich toll. Also wir haben ja dann das ganze Look und Feel so ein bisschen für das ganze diesjährige CI, sozusagen, genommen und ich finde, ja, hat schon was Russisches irgendwie auch. Also sie hat sich auch so ein bisschen orientiert, glaube ich, an diesem russischen Konstruktivismus von früher und so.
Ja, aber nicht so romantisierend russisch, oder?
Ne, eben, also so modern.
Neues gutes Design aus Moskau.
Das habe ich mir schon manchmal gedacht, ich hätte eigentlich ganz gerne manchmal noch mehr Informationen im Judy Heftli. Es ist ja sehr reduziert auf die Sticker und das hat ja sicher auch seinen Sinn. Aber zum Beispiel die Techniken, wie manche Bilder zustande kommen, das ist gerade dann auf den kleineren Stickern. Manchmal sitzt man da minutenlang davor und guckt sich das an. Das ist natürlich auch was Schönes und ist auch sicher toll für den Künstler. Aber ich habe mir schon häufiger gedacht, Mensch, da würde ich jetzt gerne mal wissen, was hat der oder diejenige sich dabei gedacht? Wie ist das entstanden? Zum Teil kann man als Laie, der ich bin, dann auch gar nicht mehr so genau nachvollziehen. Okay, ist das jetzt manuell gemacht worden und danach vielleicht noch am Computer bearbeitet oder vielleicht nur am Computer? Ich glaube, relativ viel wird noch wirklich manuell gemacht und man erahnt es vielleicht gar nicht.
Ja, das mache ich mir auch gleich, eine Notiz.
Aber das ist ein ganz guter Ansatz, dass die Künstler nicht so gerne über ihre Tricks sprechen.
Ja, gut, aber ich meine so ein bisschen Making-of oder so ein bisschen. Es gibt ja manchmal, es gibt ja dann irgendwie manchmal Medienberichte, die eben zu den Künstlern fahren und da sieht man dann, wie die arbeiten und die Sachen machen.
Aber wo sind die Hintergedanken einfach so?
Ja, dass man da so vielleicht kleine Interviews oder so ein paar Bilder aus dem Atelier, das wäre, da könnte man vielleicht auch so ein bisschen noch einen digitalen Beigeschmack haben, wie man das Internet anschauen könnte. Wir haben ja übrigens, Peru, da will ich jetzt nicht zu viel verraten, da hat es so, wenn man die Bilder mit dem Handy fotografiert, dann kommt es, also die haben ja so ein QR-Code hinten in dieser Meile. Da gibt es dann noch eine Überraschung zum Beispiel.
Guck mal an, richtig digital seid ihr da.
Ja, also der Künstler hat das wie in Eigenregie auch gemacht.
Das QR-Code sich endlich mal für was nützt.
Genau, genau, und da kann man dann wirklich zu jedem Überraschung.
Schön, schön. Die Frage, die sich jetzt fast noch ein bisschen aufdrängt, ist, wie lange sitzt denn du, Silvan, an so einem Jutti-Häftle? Das hört sich fast nach einem Jahresjob an.
Ja, also es gibt schon ruhige Phasen, aber ich bin jetzt auch seit zwei Jahren habe ich tatsächlich eine 20% Stelle beim Jutti-Häftle, weil das sonst gar nicht mehr gegangen wäre. Die ganzen Vorbereitungen und Nachbereitungen und dann eben auch die Peakphase. Aber ja, es ist natürlich schon im Moment, ich sage jetzt mal seit Anfang Jahr, ist es eigentlich fast ein Fulltime-Job. Neben meinem anderen Job, den ich noch habe. Ich bin ja 60% arbeite ich als Coach mit Stellensuchenden im grafischen Bereich, Kommunikation und solche Dinge. Zum Glück habe ich da eben auch einen sehr unterstützenden Arbeitgeber, der mir auch ermöglicht, dass ich dann mal unbezahlt frei nehmen kann und spontan auch mal Tage ausfallen lassen kann oder kompensieren kann, dass ich dann eben für die Peak-Phase im Jutti-Heftli da dann immer schön Zeit finde. Aber ich sitze schon auch oft, nicht nur jetzt heute, sondern auch sonst, oft abends hier im Büro die letzten Wochen. Also die Woche jetzt vor dem Release habe ich eigentlich im Büro gelebt, so ein bisschen auf Kosten meiner Frau, meiner Kinder, die dann mich jetzt nicht so viel gesehen haben. Dafür haben meine beiden Mädchen natürlich ohne Ende Jutti. Die können sie schon fast nicht mehr sehen.
Aber du musst nicht mehr die Tüten selber packen, so wie noch ganz am Anfang.
Nee, also das wirklich zum Glück nicht mehr.
Wie macht ihr das denn dann? Also ich vermute jetzt einfach mal, dass es nicht so ist wie bei Panini, dass es bestimmte Sticker nur ganz selten gibt, sondern dass da einfach nach dem Zufallsprinzip die Tütchen gepackt werden.
Genau, die werden tatsächlich nach dem Zufallsprinzip gepackt. Man könnte das machen, dass es da seltenere gibt, aber die in unserer Drucker-High, die haben uns jetzt mal gesagt, wenn die das machen, dann müsste man das auf die Tüte draufschreiben.
Und bei Panini wird das gemacht, effektiv? Die werden sicher sehr rar gemacht.
Ich weiss nicht, die sagen schon auch immer, es gibt gleich viele von allen, aber ich weiss nicht, ob die dann regional zum Teil ein bisschen so verteilen, dass es in Deutschland mehr von dem und dem Spieler gibt und in der Schweiz mehr von dem oder weniger.
Ja, ich will jetzt auch keine Verschwörungstheorien befeuern. Ich selber sammle ja nicht mal Panini. Deswegen rede ich daher, das ist ja wie der Blinde, der übers Zehen spricht.
Genau, also ich habe da auch keine Ahnung, wie das genau ist. Ich habe Panini jetzt auch schon lange nicht mehr. Ich habe keine Zeit mehr dafür.
Man hat auch langsam ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wo eure Zeit so hingeht. Ja, so ganz leichte Andeutung. Seid ihr denn im Privaten auch Fußballfans? Peter, fangen wir an.
Ja, schon. Nicht mehr so verbissen wie vielleicht noch als Teenager. Aber doch, schon interessiert. FC Zürich, Südkurve, ja ja. Ich bin ja nicht der Luzern-Ben.
Ich habe mir gedacht, Peter, wie die meisten Illustrator, die haben gar nichts mit Fußball.
Zu cool für Fußball? Nee, nee. Ich finde es grundsätzlich sowieso Sport ein Supergenerator für Emotionen. Und was ich jetzt in letzter Zeit noch fast lieber schaue, ist Rad-Rennen. Paris-Roubaix war am Wochenende. Sport ist einfach ein geiler Generator für Emotionen. Und deshalb finde ich es toll.
Und fiebert ihr dann auch mit der Schweizer Mannschaft mit? Ich muss mir mal gerade die Gruppe zusammen googeln. Ich hatte sie noch nicht vor Augen. Mit Brasilien, Serbien und Costa Rica darf sich die Schweizer voneinander setzen. Das heisst, dem Titel steht eigentlich nur Costa Rica im Weg?
Ja, kann man so sagen. Also ich habe das schon ausgerechnet, wie das geht. Wir müssen ja im Achtelfinale Deutschland ausschalten. Dann geht es mit Polen weiter. Und dann können wir, glaube ich, uns revanchieren an Argentinien für 2014. Und im Finale können wir dann zum zweiten Mal gegen Brasilien gewinnen. So sieht es aus.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich da jetzt aus sportlicher Sicht einwenden sollte. Das hört sich eben nicht ab. Im Grunde muss man die WM jetzt gar nicht mehr sehen. Es reicht, ein paar Bildchen zu kleben. Jetzt müssen wir aber auf jeden Fall auch noch loswerden. Wo kriegt man denn jetzt eigentlich das Judy-Häftli und die Bildchen?
Grundsätzlich auf Judy.de, das ist die Seite für Deutschland, wo man alle Infos kriegt, wo man sie kriegt. In Deutschland dieses Jahr ziemlich flächendeckend an Klosken.
Wie schreibt man denn das, Silvan?
Judy, T-S-C-H-U-T-T-I. Man kann sagen, wo es die 11 Freunde gibt, da kriegt man sie. Viel mehr Spass gibt es auf Judy.de, auch unsere Oldschool-Verkaufsstellen, Buchhandlungen, die schon seit Anfang dabei sind. Da macht es natürlich noch mehr Spass, weil die organisieren dann auch Tauschbörsen für die Sammler und ein bisschen Rahmenprogramme. Da würde ich jetzt als persönliche Empfehlung schauen, ob man in der Nähe jemanden hat von diesen Sonderverkaufsstellen, die eben auch auf Judy.de aufgeführt sind. Weil das ist dann wirklich so das Tauschfeeling, das man auch machen kann.
Ich kann auch sehr empfehlen, die Freunde noch dazu animieren, sich auch die Heftli zu besorgen. So habe ich es 2010 gemacht, da habe ich einfach noch vier andere ins Brot geholt und habe gesagt, ihr müsst euch das bitte auch bestellen, dann tauschen wir untereinander. Dann kann man sich auch sicher sein, dass man auch ohne Briefumschläge – das muss ich dann am Schluss, glaube ich, für die letzten zehn Sticker habe ich dann auch irgendwelche Briefumschläge durch Halbdeutschland geschickt. Das war aber auch irgendwie sehr nett, weil man so wusste, derjenige freut sich jetzt über diesen ollen Schweizer, den ich 13 Mal schon habe. Und ich kriege dafür endlich der eine Kroate, der mir noch fehlt.
Da gibt es auch diese App Sticker Manager, mit der wir zusammenarbeiten, wo man das auch noch so via moderner Technik machen kann.
Und Post.
Was glaubst du denn, Silvan? Tschutti Heftli im Jahr 2025. Werdet ihr Panini schon ersetzt haben? Für den guten Zweck?
Ich glaube, da wird noch die grosse Herausforderung von Katar 2022 auf uns warten. Das wird ja dann nicht mehr ein Tschutti Heftli, sondern ein Tschutti Büchli. Oder ein Tschutti Buch. Wie viele Teams sind da schon wieder geplant?
128 nicht ganz, aber es dürften schon viele sein.
Eine ziemliche Menge. Mal schauen. Ich glaube, wir machen das immer so. Wir ziehen Bilanz nach jedem Jahr oder nach jeder Ausgabe und schauen auch, ob wir noch Spass daran haben. Haben wir noch eine neue Idee, die wir machen wollen? Jetzt eben die U13, habe ich gesagt. Oder wir haben diesmal auch diese Matchplakate, die Grafiker gemacht haben. Zu jedem Spiel gibt es ein Plakat. Das sind so Sachen, die das für uns spannend machen. Und wenn das so weitergeht, und ja, dieses Jahr ist England zum ersten Mal auch als Verkaufs, haben wir einen Shop, einen Online-Shop in England, wo man das bestellen kann. Das sind so Sachen, die es dann für uns spannend machen.
Heisst da auch Heftli?
Moment, heisst da auch Chuty Heftli, ja. Eigentlich, ja, mal schauen. In Deutschland war das immer so ein bisschen, ja, das klingt so ein bisschen schweizerisch. Das ist, glaube ich, ein gutes Verkaufsargument in Deutschland.
Ihr habt auch die schönste UAL aller Zeiten. Ich finde es schade, dass man inzwischen auf Chutyli gehen soll als Deutscher. Denn die eigentliche UAL ist ja ChutyHeft.li.
Ja, genau, also eben. Bis jetzt heisst es noch Chuty Heftli auch in England. Mal schauen, wie das jetzt in England läuft überhaupt. Weil England ist schon auch ein Markt, also ein Markt, ein Land auch, das Illustrationen sehr gross schreibt. Das ist, glaube ich, da auch in Alltagszeitungen präsenter als in der Schweiz oder auch in Deutschland, glaube ich. Und Fußball natürlich sowieso. Also ich bin jetzt echt gespannt, wie die Kombination in England ankommt. Und ja, dann schauen wir dann, wie es weitergeht. Und wie viel man wachsen kann, ohne eben Panini zu werden, sage ich jetzt mal.
Kommerzialisiert.
Ja, dass es dann eben diese, ich sage jetzt mal, diese Seele ein bisschen verliert, die im Moment, glaube ich, noch da ist. Aber das ist so die Gratwanderung. Mal schauen.
Ja, wichtig wird, glaube ich, halt immer sein, dass so Leute wie Peter, auch wenn nicht gerade eine Aufnahme läuft, sagen, es macht mir Spass und es ist mir den Aufwand wert, weil ich auch dafür etwas zurückbekomme. Und wenn es Aufträge sind, ist es der bestmögliche Fall. Aber es kann ja auch einfach nur Freude an dem Projekt sein.
Ach ja, genau. Und das andere ist ja, sobald kleine, tolle Sachen in Anklang wachsen, werden größer. Aber das muss es ja nicht unsympathischer machen oder weniger liebenswert oder so.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt an ein Event zurückdenke, am Freitag, da war echt so eine gute Stimmung. Es waren so viele gute Leute, die von weit her gekommen sind. Alle haben zum ersten Mal ihre eigenen Sticker angeguckt und haben gegenseitig so gezeigt. Schau mal, welches hast du gemacht? Die einen konnten kein Wort Englisch oder Deutsch, die anderen kein Wort Russisch. Aber trotzdem ging das irgendwie alles… Ja, das ist dann auch so der Moment, wo ich denke, ja, das lohnt sich alles absolut, dieser ganze Aufwand, wenn ich so einen Abend erlebe. Und ja, da ist einfach wirklich viel, viel Herzblut und Freude dabei. Solange das so ist, machen wir das weiter.
Was sind das für ein Gefühl, Peter, wenn man die eigenen Kunstwerke als Sticker in den Händen hat?
Ja, super. Das ist halt schade, bei uns entfällt halt das Sammeln, weil wir bekommen natürlich, was auch mega toll ist, wir bekommen natürlich eine ganze Box und dann geht es nur noch ans Einkleben. Aber es ist mega toll. Ich habe jeweils ein paar in meiner Brieftasche, in meiner Portemonnaie und kann sie so ein bisschen verteilen. Du kannst sie natürlich nicht irgendwo in den öffentlichen Raum kleben, weil da ja noch dein Name drauf ist. Sie sind halt wirklich sehr klein, aber trotzdem, das Auge ist ja eine sehr effiziente Zoom-Maschine, da kann man da unglaublich nah ran und er kennt das eigentlich sehr gut.
Man kann sich auch super noch zweitverwerten. Ich habe mir immer meine Doppelten aufgehoben. Bei mir sind zum Beispiel alle Leitz-Ordner mit irgendwelchen Dokumenten. Jeder hat ein Bildliebe bekommen und das hat immer einen Sinn. Zum Beispiel der Rechnungsordner. Da ist ein ganz böse, grimmig dreimblickender Türke drauf, der wurde in einem recht aggressiven Illustrationsstil gebracht.
Die roten, die so knallrot sind.
Da kriegt man immer gleich die richtige Stimmung, wenn man zu diesem Rechnungsordner greifen muss.
Die sammeln sich dann natürlich auch in den Schubladen. In 20 Jahren kommen die wieder hervor.
Ein wirklich, wirklich schönes Projekt. Ich wünsche euch, dass das noch ganz viel Erfolg hat. Und dass es dir, Peter, ganz, ganz viele Aufträge bringt. Und du, Silvan, immer noch genügend Energie hast, das alles so durchzuziehen. Das ist eine wirklich schöne Sache. Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass viele Hörerinnen und Hörer vielleicht dieses Jahr auf das große Konkurrenzprodukt verzichten und sich das kleine Independent-Projekt holen. Und dann sagen können, ich kannte es schon, bevor es cool wurde. Weil das wird nämlich unmittelbar nach Veröffentlichung dieser Folge wahrscheinlich geschehen.
Ja, ich kann ja noch Bilder finden, das können wir noch aus so was zeigen oder was die Leute anschauen können.
Sehr gerne. Wenn du mir noch was schickst, dann packe ich das gerne auf die Seite. Und dann könnt ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da mal drauf gucken und dann eben chuty.de besuchen oder chutyheft.ly, allein nur, weil die URL so schön ist. Und dann könnt ihr euch da einen Eindruck verschaffen. Und wie gesagt, es kostet viel, viel weniger. Es ist nicht gewinnorientiert. Man spendet noch etwas für den guten Zweck. Ich denke, das ist eine Menge an guten Gründen, warum man sich damit mal auseinandersetzen kann. Ich danke euch zwei. Ich weiss nicht, ob ihr noch irgendwas auf dem Herzen habt.
Äh, nee, da habe ich so viel geredet. Also gut, es gibt auch – wir haben auch eine Facebook-Seite. Da drauf ist im Moment ein Video. Also wir haben ein tolles Video gemacht, das mit den Schweizer Spielern zu tun hat. Und da ist das größte Chuty-Bildli der Welt rausgekommen. Das lohnt sich sicher auch, das anzuschauen. Oh ja, absolut. Chuty-Häftli auf Facebook.
Das kann man sich angucken, kann ich auch nur sehr empfehlen. Dann danke ich euch beiden sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Vielen Dank. Und alles Gute auf beiden.
Danke auch, hat sehr Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich. Und danke auch an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die sich dieses 18. Tribüngengespräch angehört habt, dass so ein bisschen den Auftakt bittet zu den WM-Sendungen im Rasenfunk. Es wird täglich einen Kurzpass geben. Es wird zu allen deutschen Spielen eine Schlusskonferenz geben und weitere Tribünengespräche wie dieses hier. Das heißt, zur WM werdet ihr die volle Rasenfunk-Dröhnung bekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und warum kann ich das tun? Weil ihr uns unterstützt. Vielen Dank dafür. Und bis zur nächsten Rasenfunk-Sendung. Ich freue mich auf euch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.